el ascenso de alexéi navalni inició en
2008 cuando comenzó a escribir un blog
sobre presuntas actividades corruptas en
algunas de las mayores empresas
controladas por el estado ruso conocido
por no andarse con rodeos el carismático
abogado educado en yale ha calificado al
partido de vladimir putin como un lugar
de ladrones y estafadores navalny pronto
se convirtió en un nombre familiar tras
liderar las masivas manifestaciones en
2011 que sacaron a miles de personas a
las calles de moscú para protestar en
contra del fraude electoral en las
elecciones parlamentarias fue arrestado
después de esta primera manifestación
que fue el comienzo de una serie de
problemas legales para el hombre de 44
años en 2013 el activista anticorrupción
fue encarcelado brevemente por
malversación de fondos pero fue liberado
inesperadamente para presentarse como
alcalde de moscú quedando en segundo
lugar su condena por malversación de
fondos fue finalmente anulada tras una
sentencia del tribunal europeo de
derechos humanos pero se le impuso una
sentencia suspendida de cinco años
un nuevo juicio en 2017 que le impidió
competir en las elecciones
presidenciales de 2018 en las elecciones
regionales de rusia del año pasado
navalny creó una lista de candidatos de
la oposición que desafiaron al partido
rusia unida de putin preparando el
terreno para los comicios al parlamento
del próximo año pero las presiones
aumentaron y las autoridades hicieron
una redada en las oficinas de la
fundación anticorrupción de naval ni su
equipo dice que sospechan que su
anterior hospitalización el verano
pasado se debiera a un envenenamiento
pero los médicos dijeron que fue una
crisis alérgica